c'est soir effectivement nous recevons
un prince charmant c'est vincent lindon
a déclaré au magazine femmes j'aurais m
j'aurais aimé être le favori du roi à la
cour de louis xiv
alors pour lui 14 c'est un peu râpé puis
vance peut-être quelqu'un
2006 avis est banal effectivement les
frais ces dix ans de cinéma et son
meilleur ami c'est patrick bruel c'est
une banalité affligeante
il paraît que ses deux idoles c'est
michel drucker et rambo
et puis les nature il dit qu'il ne
cultive aucun look c'est vrai qu'il a
plutôt le look dépanneur darty moi je
lui confiera bien voilà
on est pas qu il ait un côté belmondo
plutôt que ses rouflaquettes et sa
démarche de cow boy les nouveaux bancs
90 il disait qu'il avait 4 ans et demi
d'âge mental alors il paraît qu'elle a
grandi depuis mots je mens bien savoir
quel âge il a maintenant et va on va lui
demander tout de suite vincent lindon
et
quelle horatio caine ovation récent 1
donc bon soir alors
que je vous avais parce que après tout
c'est vrai le lot demande qu'elle a joué
aux avis jeu mental ou non aux réelles
33 ah oui les jeunes pas vécu cette
histoire de 82,8 âge mental le lot mais
ces vies qui la voient leur ai dit je
veux dire ça va vous maintenez
normes ce et l'expressionnisme alors le
look vincent
dépanneurs sont rouges le look dépanneur
darty s entraîne un peu hard non ça vous
non genon je sais pas vous n'êtes pas de
bal où j'ai mieux je vais rendre malade
un peu peur donc non je suis j'ai mis un
pull bleu marine
on voit non mais vous avez enlevé
probablement dans deux milieux de
travail très très chaud vous n'êtes pas
donc du style costard cravate c'est
aussi des fois je me dis je vous si ces
gens mais quand quantifie je déteste les
gens qui qui ne met pas les affaires
qu'il faut mettre pour les cérémonies où
il faut aller je dis à quelqu'un qui va
à cannes et qui se tape un georges moi
je vais pas ce week-end je trouve ça va
bien vous menez des trucs au moment où
il faut et puis tu entends je mets un
costume par exemple si vous allez à
cannes vous y allez habillé comme un
comme tout le monde mais un smoking et
un
tout le monde alors vous dites que vos
devis et banale effectivement
effectivement vous fêtez vous disant
cinéma votre meilleur pote c'est bruel
effectivement c'est affligeant de
banalité non mais non je dis bah ma vie
banale non ma vie elle est formidable
mais je dis que dans le temps que quand
on vous pose des questions dans
interview on nous demande mais alors
quand vous faites pas du cinéma qu'est
ce que vous faites je dis pas ce que je
fais c'est d'un banal déconcertant je
fais comme tout le monde mais qu'est ce
que vous faites
quand vous faites pas de cinéma jeux je
lis je regarde la télé je vois bouge pas
beaucoup mais je lis un bon prix mais
vous lis pas trop
les natures les matières mais je lis un
peu oui
je regarde la télé je vois beaucoup mes
copains vous voyez beaucoup je fais ma
sport tout ça vous fait du sport qu'est
ce que vous faites en sorte que ça se
voit pas dans
le jeu je cours chez l'udinese je joue
au foot maze est un petit gars musclés
c'est pour savoir si une question oui je
suis un petit gars musclés et pas
vincent lindon en tout cas on est ravis
de vous accueillir à froufrous on passe
une heure en votre compagnie et tout de
suite on va passer à star à la une
c
vincent lindon avant d'attaquer une
question indiscrète pour se mettre en
bouche oui ça serait peut être
vous n'êtes absolument pas obligé de
répondre mais bon on lit détruites dans
les journaux alors on aimerait savoir la
vérité n'est pas c'est à dire mais
attendez non je rigole qui yat il
exactement entre vous et patrick bruel
au japon we say say say say say bon
c'est mon ami l'ifa c'est plus qu'un
pote c'est mon ami c'est bon c'est fait
partie de mes trois meilleurs amis c'est
quelqu'un à qui je dis tout qui me dit
tout et est acquis jeu dont je me
réjouis du succès dont il se réjouit de
mon succès et eau et on s'est dit on se
fait aucun piège donc se connaissent et
toute sa vie toute sa vie non j'en
connais jean connaît autant que j'y
connais la mienne beaucoup et oui je me
raconte cette rue comme des amis il ya
une femme
il paraît que vous base passer des
heures au téléphone avec lui vous
pourriez pas nous fier son numéro foot
en direct d'ailleurs vous voix au
téléphone
mais c'est qui c'est c'est eh oui c'est
moi mais c'est je sais que c'est mal
c'est sûrement un nom qui vous la donner
quoi oui oui c'est maman abordant
quelques pillages l'appartement la
semaine dernière à temps au pire il ya
eu pillages alors vincent vous êtes
nominé
césar c'est vrai pour la crise vous êtes
content franchement football c'est vrai
ah oui ça alors là je suis fou de joie
il ya des gens qui tentent en veulent
pas avouer que les récompenses
quand on les a mais même les honneurs
font plaisir non moi je suis fou de joie
mais vous avez souvent la console mais
si mais si mais j'ai une autre question
voilà mais oui mais je voulais vous dire
vous avez souvent joué les losers quand
même les mecs plaqué par leurs femmes
par exemple dans la crise c'est le cas
non seulement ça c'est un mec normal
c'est pas le
couple est alors dans quelques jours
avec moi de claude sautet sandrine
bonnaire vous larguer pour daniel
auteuil oui dans un homme amoureux de
diane kurys votre copine greta scacchi
tombe amoureuse de peter coyote remarqué
ça c'est énorme
non
aussi crûment mais va nous mettre
l'organisme
c'est peter coyote quand même c'est
peter coyote d'ailleurs aux normes et
moi ce que j'aurais vous dire c'est que
justement grâce au succès de la crise
maintenant c'est les autres qu'on va
larguer bon mois
vous êtes vraiment comme ça dans la vie
sert vous vous êtes fait souvent plaquer
pour débiteurs coyotes
oui j'en souvent non c'est du moins ce
qu on appelle souvent si souvent c'est
cent fois non mais 4,5 fois oui mais
vous vous avez mais vous avez souvent
joué des rôles de cocu quand même
vincent lindon est ce que les
réalisateurs trouve vous avez
spécifiquement une tête de cocu rien du
tout c'est à dire que là on leur en leur
disant il vante de ses amis ses prix
moi je vous remercie beaucoup déjà pour
l'aide mais non non non mais c'est
cia il ya plein d'acteurs qui hausse moi
je suis pas mal d'être ne perdant dans
une histoire d'amour c'est en tout cas
cinématographiquement cccc assez payant
alors valérie alors d'écouter en lisant
la presse du monde entier je me suis
rendu compte que de nous les femmes on
vit vraiment une époque formidable que
tout est fait pour nous simplifier la
vie
par exemple finie la corvée de descendre
les ordures parce qu'évidemment c'est
toujours nous les femmes qui descendent
dont les poubelles dit
[Applaudissements]
nos archives soir je vous descendez les
poubelles jeu
non vous descendez les poubelles jacente
c'est comme s'il ya plus de portillons
dans le métro il ya plus habitué à la
poubelle alors dit observeur magazine le
dit que bientôt il n'y aura plus de
poubelles en grande bretagne en est en
train de tenter une expérience de
remplacer les poubelles par des cuves en
plastique dans lesquels on met des verts
des vers de terre quel genre de vers de
terre
ce genre de vers de terre des lombrics
sa place et vous avez s'achever joue sa
date a plaidé l'ombre écrit et vinci 1 à
100 par poubelle est alors leur part de
lloris 754 milliards sur terre el haddad
et leurs particularités ses deux coups
des meneurs en verre hyper musclé j'ai
mangé cette poubelle
l'auteur décédé lecteurs en partie de
leurs particularités c'est qu'ils le
peuvent régurgiter les détritus ce une
famille de quatre personnes en 24 heures
voilà il ya des règles en plus de faire
parler d'elle il ya des règles à
respecter quand même parce qu'il faut
pas leur donner à manger de poisson ni
de viande parce que là ils se mettent à
dégager une odeur ses silences
au passé mais il faut faire attention
aussi parce que vous les recevez par la
poste
ou c'est vrai c'est donc tout est normal
et donc et donc il faut bien faire
attention de mettre un filtre au dessus
des verts pour quand même paye pour
qu'ils se barrent ben
ouais enfin je vois une autre invention
aussi toujours nanties observeur qu'il
va vous plaire j'en suis sûr parce que
d'habitude dans les supermarchés j'suis
sûr vous choisissez toujours la caisse
où il ya le moins de monde oui et là ça
va changer grâce aux cadis télévision
parce qu'il ya une chaîne de
supermarchés aux états unis qui a fait
installer des petits téléviseurs sur
lesquels gm comme ça on pourra regarder
froufrous en faisant son marché
le supermarché de façon anonyme à une
wii judicaire je passe pas devant tout
le monde dans marie claire vis c'est pas
une invention mais c'est une nouvelle
utilisation d'un objet qu'on connaît
très bien c'est le pantalon vous dise le
contraceptif le plus sur ton pantalon
alors je comprends pas et bah moi non
plus on saurait qui nous explique ce que
ça veut dire que j avais pas pensé avant
que le pantalon pouvait être content lui
sert si on retire pas j'en sais rien
facile vous il ya certes quelques
éléments de la bae démontré comment
je ne crois pas ce jeune homme élevé
parce qu'il voulait dire exactement
temps non là vous allez me quoi on
peut continuer dans les autres ce qui
n'est vous allez faire la tête de cette
jeune femme une publicité pour un test
de grossesse alors elle fait la gueule
carrément d'habitude on vous montrait
des vents les femmes épanouies ravie
heureuse et bien là elle fait la gueule
et en plus on vous insulte dans la
publicité on vous dit si vraiment vous
pensez que vous êtes enceinte est ce que
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment dans la
merde comme ça pour choisir un test de
grossesse compliquée c'est
moi que c'est quand même fort mineurs et
aux états unis mais c'est dans les
journaux britanniques et américains ce
que vous en pensez mais sans sa maman
c'est étonnant ce chaton attendez c'est
pas triste parce que dans le
cosmopolitan américain j'ai vu cette
publicité pour le centre d'adoption open
adoption center c'est à dire que c'est
s'adresse au maire aux jeunes femmes qui
sont enceintes et qui veulent faire
adopter leurs enfants alors vous pouvez
choisir vos parents vous pouvez choisir
donc les parents de votre futur enfant
vous pouvez choisir si vous continuerez
avoir des contacts avec l'enfant et en
plus on vous dit tous les frais seront
payés et c'est une pub c'est une bulle
bah oui oui alors qu'est ce que vous
pourriez vous pensé de sa vague
seigneurie mezui la maladie
alors guy roux et la semaine prochaine
le journal elle coûtera 14 francs au
lieu de 13 francs mais sur ces 14 francs
il ya deux francs qui seront reversés
pour les femmes en bosnie grâce à la icf
qui va qui veut apporter des médicaments
et des produits de première nécessité en
bosnie c'est un geste de solidarité peut
pas faire grand chose pour les violences
gnac mais au moins on peut acheter et
voilà lundi
j'ai rencontré des jeunes gens géniaux
qui font partie d'une organisation qui
s'appelle première urgence qui sont si
jeunes qui sont les derniers qui peuvent
aller en ex-yougoslavie et ils font
passer des camions pour donner des
denrées à tous les gens qui sont là bas
c'est ici qu'ils y sont six ces six
jeunes ces six français qui ont fondé
cette organisation et qui travaillent
qui sont en contact permanent avec avec
kouchner et toute son organisation ils
sont six ils font des choses formidables
ils essaient de contacter des artistes
pour qu'on les aide et la plus grande
aide qu'on peut leur faire cesser de
dire leur nom de donner la ccpc ce que
vous voyez en ce moment les envoyait à
l'écran et d'envoyer un tout petit peu
d'argent parce qu'un camion ça coûte un
camion rempli ça coûte 15 mille francs
et donc s'il ya quinze d'une personne
qui envoie un franc il ya un camion qui
passait ben voilà
alors vous avez dit il y a deux sortes
de dragueur les très beaux qui laisse
venir et les besogneux dans mon genre
alors franchement vasselin donc vous
besogner longtemps vous avant d'attraper
une fille
franchement je ne sais pas quoi non je
ne sais pas je dis ça je dis je dis
début je dis des conneries je
sais pas moi la femme de votre vie vous
l'avait séduite comment
on est non mais non je suis normal mais
oui comme tout le monde je n'y a pas je
sais pas ça veut dire il ya des fois où
sur la question après je ne sais pas on
en croit pas quand je crois pas qu'on
séduisent des gens et je crois pas cette
phrase où les gens disent c'est un bon
coup je crois qu'ils ont séduit personne
on est on est pas un bon coup on est on
[ __ ] a perdu son vin nous montrons
veut assez craquant et on va voir que
vous étiez
[Applaudissements]
boire vincent que vous étiez très
craquant aussi quand vous étiez petit
garçon est très sportif aussi regarder
regarder
et c'est vous et si vous pouvez nous
dire vous pouvez nous raconter un peu si
ce par quoi je vous raconterai pas cessé
très ému je vous dirais alors là c'est
vous on voit que vous étiez les berges
vous grimpez sur les rochers
oui bah raconté à les y ai dit non parce
que là c'est avec les filles mais là
j'en reviens pas je vous jure je ne
regardais là vous faites du vélo vous
êtes quand même assez balèze en vélo
je vous jure je ne savais même pas que
ça existait je vous jure c'est vous avez
des belles oreilles
et puis on veut vous êtes courageux quoi
on voit que voilà quoi ou est-ce que
vous avez trouvez vous sauter dans l'eau
sans bouée et là vous embêter les filles
vous êtes ou
biarritz à vous êtes vous êtes assez
dégueulasse vous embêter les filles
voilà la première crawl premiers prônent
il
mais je vous jure notre jeune l'agencé
je n'en reviens pas alors c'est votre
maman qui nous a donné ça d'aller sur
votre mère nous a jamais montré et nous
arrive a dit yahya ben yahia 28 ans le
montrent il ya 21 ans non ce qui est
très émouvant c'est la dame au début je
raconte je vais très vite elle s'appelle
marinoni c'est une dame qui a réfugiés
mon grand père et ma grand mère et donc
ses quatre enfants mon père et ses trois
frères pendant la guerre parce qu'ils
étaient juifs et elle les a réfugié dans
sa maison en auvergne et je me souviens
qu'en fin je me souviens j'étais pas là
mais mon grand père m'a raconté qu'à ce
moment là c'était très difficile d'avoir
des oeufs et du beurre et qu'il était
arrivé très timidement dans cette ferme
il a dit j'aimerais bien en avoir six et
qu'elle lui a mené six douzaines de thé
c'est un endroit où les allemands
étaient pas venus et après la revois des
on la revoit continuer de tout et après
la guerre tous les ans mon père nous a
emmené mes deux frères et moi et toute
la famille a été à tour de rôle pour
toutes les vacances passé deux jours
jusqu'à l'appel marinoni et ben bravo
bravo
cette semaine nous allons faire le banc
d'essai de la voyance je sais pas si
vous savez en ce moment il ya le salon
parapsy à paris 1 et nous sommes quand
même 10 millions à consulter une voyante
ou un voyant tous les ans alors vincent
giret savoir vous avez déjà vu un voyant
voyant la voyance j'ai dit non j'ai eu
j'avais déjà vu je n'ai jamais eu à
écouter chez pas dans ce moment si vous
allez voir un voyant à moi - devrait une
cagoule ça va être très difficile de
vous tirer les cartes je ne veux pas
dire que les voyant surtout des
charlatans qui se fient à des petits
indices de genre mais tout de même je
pense qu'il y en a une bonne partie
elysées journaux qui lui ses journaux
qui vous remet un regard que vous
arrivez la tête aux pieds qui vous qui
êtes un petit peu au téléphone quand
vous prenez votre rendez vous donc c'est
important de savoir un petit peu comment
ils font pour ne pas se faire piéger et
le meilleur moyen pour saab assez de
jouer soi-même à la voyante et on
comprend bien comment ça se passe alors
que le matos il faut le matos alors le
matos moi je les trouvais on trouve
autour aussi entre partout et j'ai
trouvé à paris chez dans une boutique
une librairie ésotérique qui s'appelle
l'astro club ça se trouve aussi en
province partout vous avez le tarot vous
avez le pendule vous avez bien sûr la
boule de cristal est donc là sans jouer
on va compenser en surveillant vous
allez faire le client vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis si vous êtes très intéressé
de savoir que je vous parle de votre
avenir
oui oui c'est intéressant que vous aviez
13 13 lettres dans votre nom et prénom
vous ne saviez pas moi j'ai l'impression
que le cloud et que le chiffre 13 a
beaucoup compté dans votre vie est ce
que c'est vrai ya de fortes la pollution
charbon est devenu
alors voilà donc voilà très stressé car
un bon copain monde il est voyant ses
pas il met la com
comment je peux savoir si oui c'est pas
juste avant c'est justement vous allez
pas alors donc voilà que treize cartes
alors vous allez bien les mélanger bien
les battre pour leur communiquer notre
énergie cosmi c'est très très important
mais moi pendant ce temps je prends
votre main pour comics vous me
communiquer vos
je peux avoir une voyance ça y est j'ai
remué bon alors nous allons nous allons
les retourner will a donc jeté mais face
à vous vous avez un avenir antisida m
vous allez voir alors voulez-vous qu'on
sent très bien voulu regarder et vous
allez en tirer une celle qui vous
inspire le plus on va voir si ça
m'inspire une voyance alors je ne vais
pas n'importe comment je l'aimais selon
la maison carrée triangulaire taïwan
vous voyez c'est là alors ça c'est la
carte de l'eau à l'interdît je vois je
vais d'étendues d'eau je vois une
étendue de vous vivez vous visez prêts
d'honneur non alors vous allez sûrement
des ménages est
peut-être suite à une union un mariage
je vois une ville avec de l'eau tour que
d'être une ville méditerranéenne
c'est combattre et que les voyantes j'ai
toujours très facile en fait quand vous
rentrez dans un cabinet de voyance ce
qui est difficile pour une voyante ce
sont les dix premières minutes je parle
pour les voyantes qui sont un peu
charlatans parce qu'elle vous
connaissent pas donc elles ont besoin de
vous faire parler de vous mettre un
petit peu en confiance et pour ça il
faut faire qu elle ratisse large donc
elle commence à dire des prédictions
extrêmement large vous voyez le genre je
vois une étendue d'eau et cetera puis
petit à petit on se met à parler et ça
et il a beaucoup
mais moi j'avais des amis si je lis les
journaux
alors autres alors donc il ya
effectivement la fameuse boule de
cristal alors problème de la boule de
cristal quand on n'est pas très doué
d'abord c'est qu'il faut la soulever moi
j'arrive même pas et en plus il faut pas
la faire tomber parce que ça coûte quand
même plus de samedi france ça ouais ou
de s'annoncer du principal oui on va
quand même un terreau je suis là à
vincent vous allez me suivre oui j'aime
car dans le jeu une caste va sans
attiser et vous allez voir c'est trouver
un guéridon un vieux bidon ce matin
c'est un guéridon tout à fait normal
vous pouvez le regarder il n'a rien de
bizarre vous pouvez regarder tout mais
ça va j'ai fait normal j'ai gonflé alors
on va le questionner ce guéridon alors
d'abord je vais regarder la carte vous
avez tiré vous avez tiré l'avocat
s'était alors blessé c'est un point dans
vous avez tiré la carte de l'amour et de
l'union d'accord alors on va être
registre aigu doit être c'est pas moi
qui parle à celle au-delà donc je
demande c'est une femme d'en mettre dans
mon coeur et ma vie ça à la rigolade au
delà oui oui
alors allez-y mollo de la sq il y a
quelqu'un dans la vie d'un broker là ça
va bouger accord
laissez votre carrière est ce que
vincent va avoir une heureuse surprise
aux césars
mêmes atouts prélat aller
ça va combien ça on peut en avoir une et
là ça coûte environ 30 mille francs
comment ça commence à sa maladie on ne
le sera jamais par contre si vous voulez
voir ce genre de choses bougent et je
voulais même voir des fantômes traverser
les murs il ya un musée qui va s'ouvrir
à paris sur 1500 mètres carrés ça sera
le musée la curiosité de la magie dans
le marais à partir du 10 avril et là
vraiment agréable et vous verrez la
table et on nous explique comment elle
marche ou pas des marches swing merci et
merci
[Musique]
dans cette semaine on va voir comment
garder un homme alors à ce sujet on a
tout entendu il faut mettre de la
lingerie sexy il faut faire des petits
plats il faut juste et de grands regard
émerveillé et bref faire sa petite
geisha sauf que moi j'ai constaté dans
mon entourage que ce sont justement les
petites guichard que les hommes ne
sait-on b alors alors je pense qu'il
serait malin de changer de stratégie
d'accord mais alors comment garder un
homme laurence alors d'abord il faut
arrêter de rêver un couple s'est jamais
gagné 75 % des demandes et divorce vient
des femmes alors rappelé lui des
chiffres effectifs selon lui donner
envie un petit peu de ça comprend pas
qu'ils fassent pas le malin toute la
journée
ensuite il bon il faut bien lui faire
comprendre qu'on n'est pas du genre
crampons glisser les petites phrases
dans la conversation par exemple soupiré
ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs mais quand je
pense que j'ai même pas ma chambre
c'est fini oui j'ai des copains nom
était tout rouge âgées soit
des partis deux jours j'ai pu enfin
dormir en travers j'étais chez moi mais
ça on est très simple oui oui a avoué
dans dix ans je ne sais pas ce que je
ferais sans préciser ni avec qui on a
compris
alors toujours voulu faire réfléchir il
parlait lui de vos copains qui ont
quitté leurs femmes par exemple de ce
pouf philippe qui est obligé de revendre
sa bm cityzi maintenant ça va vite ça
coûte cher une
pension alimentaire ou alors dans toi tu
travailles 16 heures par jour avec le
nul c'est la somme à force de vous le
dire des big burgers
rappelez-lui sans arrêt que il ya des
gars qui s'en sortent pas du tout créer
entre un point sur la majorité
alors il faut aussi cultiver un couple
repoussoir alors un peu le repoussoir ce
n'est pas ça frise la coupe de copains
qui est vraiment nul voilà l'organisaion
tout le temps
vous invitez et du gazon et vous laisser
voler du gaz on vous laissait cette
chaire marie-ange par les sept chats
mariage qui ne supporte pas que son mari
fut ma table on le voit très bien et
qu'il se laisse pousser la petite
moustache enfin la connais parce que je
suis un homme de tu vois j'ai eu à vous
je suis quand même beaucoup moins de
chance que marion
cb cook le repoussoir vincent lindon
des coupes kim jong il et oublient
qu'ils arrêtent pas de singles oui il ya
pire que parce que s'engueuler ça va on
peut à terme et en fait ça va arrêter
non mais c'est décourageant kicks et la
femme qui prend toujours la parole pour
le mes ou emerson voilà ça c'est
terrible ça je connais un couple vous
pose des questions aux mecs sans arrêt
oui on a décidé parce que vraiment
mais c'est à lui que je parle ça c'est
terrible alors si vous pouviez balancer
des noms on se ferait pas avec ces
choses c'est pas des gens connus cdc des
cdd des gens que je fous je m'en tire
bien
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est miles a
raison ça marche en tout cas le losc ça
marche ça marche alors vous allez
cultive aussi un axe qui ressemble
étrangement à robert redford et
c'est ça à cultiver en émission celui-là
était se précipitent au cinéma avec vous
dès que votre homme part en voyage
d'affaires
vous pouvez si par exemple vincent
lindon et votre ex ça marche aussi
voilà ne le perdez pas de vue oui mais
bon ça les fortunes c'est vrai que c'est
bien mais c'est bon c'est bien ça quand
vous êtes vous resté copain avec
l'entrée vous oui il ya bien gallia
quand on a quand on a un copain qui est
très beau très bientôt de mai qu'on n'a
jamais rien eu avec lui parce que ça
peut quand même se passer si tu me
gonfles trop
oui c'est vrai explique alexia elec son
lien on peut frimer devant les classes
et moi nous oui c'est ça au cinéma il va
jouer au cinéma ces ricains qui a jamais
rien eu ça ça fait peur ça c'est une
bonne combine deux nanas va s'endormir
gc
super nanas alors attention aux périodes
de crise un quand il s'énerve qui vous
menace à peut plus dire on va divorcer
ne résistez pas vous ne résistez pas
voulu dit tu veux divorcer c'est ça tu
veux la garde des enfants l'appartement
le bonsaï yaris fait tout ça
je vais voir il à se cramponner au
canapé pour ne pas giflé
exactement ça dit l'heure tu veux les
enfants et bah si oui
ou non plus les comptes ans
après alors cela dit soyez positive il
nous faudra jamais raté une occasion
pour le motiver leur par exemple vous
pouvez lui re lire la carte de voeux de
votre amie chantal qu'elle vous a envoyé
il ya quelques temps je cite tu ne peux
pas savoir le bien que vous faites
autour de vous le monde actuel a besoin
de couple comme vous fidèles uni et fort
c'est un témoignage magnifique ce merci
d'exister
samedi une très bonne russe
washing
et puis et puis
vincent là dedans c'est le moment de
votre épreuve
alors comme c'est une surprise comme si
tu redoutes il y a une petite
préparation je vais vous demander de
regagner votre loge puisque vous n'êtes
pas au courant de ce qui se passe et on
va faire un petit chamboulement de
plateau alors vous allez dans votre loge
tout de suite dedans
alors ça y est vincent vous êtes
installés oui oui je suis là je suis là
bon alors je ne vous inquiétez pas en
vous mitonne une petite surprise sur
mesure vous allez adorer ça vous avez
peur j'espère mais c'est pas du tout
inquiétant on est enfermé dans une loge
avons préparé une surprise mais la main
sur un angoissé ça va bientôt être prêt
vous pensez que c'est quoi quel genre de
surprise j'ai aucune je sais pas du tout
je sais pas du tout mais je crains le
pire mais vous êtes vous avez une
trouille d'enfer oui c'est ça va de ce
côté-là non à tout de suite
vincent la dent vous avez dit un jour je
voudrais être ambo pour terrasser
l'injustice
il l'a dit il l'a dit d'ailleurs dans la
crise on vous admire en pleine séance de
musculation alors on ne va pas vous
demander de faire de la muscu mais on
voudrait vous aider à devenir rambo pour
terrasser l'injustice vincent alors si
vous voulez bien nous rejoindre
allez
on a donc mis à votre disposition un
vrai ring de boxe oui plus des gants
d'accord des prêtres un protège dents
voilà la
jeune et des lettres à protège des sept
zones qui étaient libérés de prison et
qui vient
vous allez vous habiller vincent lindon
parce que vous allez vous mettre en
tenue il ya un petit paravent pour vous
derrière va pas vous regarder derrière
il
ya un short et des chaussures de boxe
des gants de boxe alors d'abord vous
vous habillez et on va simplement vous
donné une vraie leçon de boxe d'accord
alors vous vous mettez en tenue
et dès que vous êtes en tenue vous nous
rejoignez sur le ring voilà
[Musique]
alors
une question mais contre qui je me bats
msk d'abord vous avez envie de vous
battre
je suis
allée revanche ça peut vous servir donc
une petite leçon si vous avez envie un
jour de frapper dans votre vie je sais
pas c'est qu'il sait qui est basse et
akim tafer le champion d'europe
à
comment ça c'est pas possible un dans
cette affaire l'idée c'est que vous
devenu une vraie leçon de boxe à vassan
l'amant parker qui disent je finisse
donc 40 alors non je voudrais savoir
s'il a un bon gauche un bon droit donc
vous allez regarder comment et sa garde
et vous allez nous dire donc le public
vous allez créer un tout petit peu moins
fort pour que hakim puisse nous dire
s'il a des qualités de boxeur alors
allez-y qu'incarne voilà on y va
alors à qui mme
[Applaudissements]
lagarde il a plusieurs mais tic
parti avec ça
c'est ici
il est un endroit mais mais devrait être
plus actifs sur les enchaînements c'est
à dire c'est à dire qu'il peut donner
une droite et enchaîné du bras arrière
directement alors dit montrait lui
comment on fait alors allez-y un vrai
cours
il est comme ça ça sans avoir à voir si
c'est le bras droit donnez nous a donné
un coup du brabant et enchaîner derrière
[Applaudissements]
m
dommage
est ce que c'est un incident qui met ce
que c'est facile de ratatiner va sans un
enfant sait pas si nos gestes oui
on vient à qui faites le
si je me demande de le but et la mana
je réagis tu vois un truc je voudrais
qu'on s'a ces voix là j'en profite oui
j'aimerais juste prendre un coup -
moitié force senor mois d'efforts est-ce
que vous donneriez en combat ici
j'arrive pas à me rendre compte si cette
nuance qui prennent là si je me mets
comme ça il donnait des coups ici la
moitié de la force pour voir ce que ça
parce que moi de
passer moi quand je regarde la
télévision et qu'on voit un boxeur qui
est là et qui se fait pas comme ça on
dit non mais ça va pas être terrible et
en fait il paraît que si bell et cogeco
enchaîné c'est vrai que ça ça coupe le
souffle et sa moitié de voir ça veut
dire c'est la moitié de ce
bruit ça ça dure
une vraie ce coup ci est fermée sirella
là et si je donne un coup comme ça non
mais c'est passé c'est ça oui d'accord
bon sens
mal à la main mois
[Applaudissements]
or
voilà
mais alors
quitte à faire bravo donc si je
récapitule vous êtes champion d'europe
lourds-légers 19 combats 16 victoires
dont 12 par ko pour une
3 défaites alors vous remettrez votre
titre de champion d'europe quand en jeu
fin avril-début mai contre qui contre un
angle et j'ai pas le dire est qu'un golf
certainement et si tout se passe bien
c'est après si j'entre dans le monde
c'est tout se passe bien on voit du
monde dans les prochains mois à venir
merci
samazan
alors en vrai comment c'était non mais
c'est impossible c'est incroyable quand
on est devant sa télé et qu'on regarde
un match de foot où va regarder un match
de boxe on donne plein de conseils et
quand un boxeur prend plein de coups ont
fait mais vas-y à l'ebu je réveille toi
c'est un enfer et messi mais parce que
c'est une masse
c'est un pylône de fatima présentement
là j'ai mal à la main là je le dis nous
mais c'est la force de coups ça veut
rien dire vous pensiez pas parce que
vous aimez bien la boxe non moi j'adore
ça la boxe non mais je suis considéré
dans les gens normaux pardon dans mes
gènes vers les gens de la rue je suis
considéré comme quelqu'un de fort je
veux dire je je suis fort et là c'est
sérieux non mais ya pas de comparaison
ça veut rien dire 700 salariés par
exemple je marche dans la rue du lac où
il joue dans la bagnole je fais qu
est-ce qui a accueilli sors et je tombe
sur lui je c'est dommage
rappelle que vous êtes nominé aux césar
pour le meilleur comédien dans la
catégorie meilleure comédie un boxeur
pour la crise le très beau film de
coline serreau donc on vous souhaite
très fort de gagner le césar parce que
là vous n'avez pas gagné le match mais
le césar on sait jamais voilà
merci akim tafer salué la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]